[Music]
Phoebe hey look maybe you wanted to hang
out it's the last summer after high
school ends the last chance to decide
who we want to be and who we want to be
with think about when you supposed to
wear to a breakup how about we agree to
stay friends just famous okay walk away
Oh for god sakes who's gonna be the
summer it's clean slate and you're
really good can't believe you're wasting
all this to study business right over a
safe stable career in the arts beach
bonfire party lay down sure yeah I'm not
actually gonna go out with him
no he's young he's successful and he's
hot
gross so what's the village human
thieves we haven't talked about it yeah
keeping the mystery alive
I'm digging me sometimes I fear whether
I'm even capable of love welcome to my
office
you're making it very hard to judge you
someone's going by way too fast I wanted
to see you before we both leave for
school hey I got it go but have an
export okay
Phoebe there's something I need to tell
you
you just went along and you did nothing
I didn't know what to do
I've never been through this before
[Music]
one last summer
the last chance to go all in
I mean what's there to lose right
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you